كثيره هي المؤشرات اذا على تطبيع وشيك بين
سوريا وتركيا قبل شهر وخلال اسبوع واحد
وجه الرئيس تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان رسالتين
سياسييتين وبينما اعلن لمرتين انه لا خلاف
ابديا في السياسه قائلا ان عقده لقاء مع
نظيره السوري امر ممكن بعد انقطاع
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه مع دمشق منذ 2011
دعمه حليفه دوله بهشتري بالقول يجب فتحه
لقاء مع الرئيس السوري وتشكيل اراده
مشتركه ضد المنظمات الارهابيه بالمناسبه
هناك خلاف في تعريف الارهاب بين انقره
ودمشق فانقر عندما تتحدث عن الارهاب تقصد
المسلحين الاكراد بينما تنظر دمشق لكل من
يحمل السلاح على انه ارهابي اضافه الى
الفصائل التي تدعمها تركيا او من ضمن ذلك
الفصائل التي تدعمها تركيا بالعوده الى
الحادي عشر من اغسطس تحدث وزير الخارجيه
تركي
عن العلاقات مع سوريا مشيرا الى انه التقى
وزير خارجيه السوري فيصل مقداد على هامش
اجتماع الحركه عدم الانحياز الذي عقد في
اكتوبر من العام الماضي في بلغراد كذلك
عقد مسؤول مخابرات البلدين عده اجتماعات
حول امكانيه تطوير العلاقات الثنائيه ثم
جاءت زياره وزير الخارجيه السوريه الى
موسكو يوم الثالث والعشرين من اغسطس لتؤكد
ان تم اتصالات تجرى ودورا روسيا واضحا
للتوفيق بين انقره ودمشق وتحقيق انفراجه
او اختراق بحيث يتم التركيز على نوع من
التعاون المشترك في مواجهه التطورات في
الشمال السوري هذه المؤشرات اظهرت وجوده
تغير في موقف انقره من دمشق حيث يتبنى
الموقف التركي الجديد تحسين العلاقات وما
يدفع للتساؤل عن اسباب هذا التغير وعن
توقيته هنا يمكن الاشاره الى بعض الدوافع
والتفسيرات اولا السياسات المتغيره للرئيس
التركي من طبيعه اردوغان ان يغير مواقفه
بصوره كبيره دو اي تحفظات وقد عكست سياسه
انقره تجاه بعض دول الاقليم هذه الطبيعه
المتغيره مثل علاقات مع اسرائيل الانتقال
من الخلاف العلني الى استلام اوراق اعتماد
السفيره الاسرائيليه امس بالتالي فان
اسلوب عمل اردوغان والتعاطيياه مع
التطورات يجعلان من تبدل موقفهم دمشق امرا
متوقعا ثانيا ضغوط الداخل على اردوغان
قضيه اللاجئين السوريين الذين يقترب عددهم
من 4 ملايين وتركز المعارضه التركيه على
ان هذه القضيه من اسباب الازمه الاقتصاديه
وان تم فشلا للرئيس ابن جان في هذا الصدد
بالتالي يسعر اردوغان الى اعاده النازحين
قبل الانتخابات المقرره في بلاده عام 20
23 حتى يتجنب هذا الضغط من الاحزاب
المعارضه
ثالثا رغبه الرئيس التركي في التفاهم مع
روسيا اردوغان يحاولوا الاستفاده من الحرب
الاوكرانيه ومصاعد موسكو لتحقيق اكبر قدر
من المكاسب سواء على مستوى الطاقه
والمسائل الاقتصاديه الاخرى ولا شك ان
روسيا تدرك ذلك جيدا وارادت في مقابل
المطالب التركيه تحقيقه مكسب يتعلق بدعم
الحكومه السوريه ومواجهه الارهاب ووقف اي
تقدم عسكري تركي في الشمال السوري